okay uh very important news involving
the new law the justice against sponsors
of terrorism act known as Jasta for
short this is the law that president
obama vetoed recently but that veto was
then overridden by the house and senate
and what it allows is for victims of 911
in the united states up families of
victims of 911 in the united states to
sue saudi arabia and then it would be uh
evaluated whether or not Saudi Arabia
provided material support to some of the
perpetrators of the 911 attacks which as
we know were overwhelmingly from Saudi
Arabia well Stephanie Ross DeSimone and
her 14 year old daughter Alexandra are
now the first to sue Saudi Arabia under
the new law allowing these lawsuits
prior to Jasta passing US citizens could
only sue Sudan Syria and Iran in the
event of a terrorist attack carried out
by those states now Stephanie Ross
desimone and her daughter uh who are
respectively the widow and daughter of a
naval commander killed during the 911
attacks are suing and uh they're suing
because D Simone's husband of two years
US Navy Commander Patrick Dunne was
working at the Pentagon when american
airlines flight 77 crashed into the
headquarters of the US military and the
lawsuit completely as expected alleges
that quote at all material times saudi
arabia through its officials officers
agents and employees provided material
support and resources to Osama bin Laden
and al-qaeda uh this document doesn't
say how much money desimone is seeking
in damages from saudi arabia everyone
who listens to this show knows that i am
not a war hawk i am not a warmonger but
i want to step back just for a second
here if it's true that the Saudi
government or senior Saudi officials are
responsible for 911 in some way that is
provable in court then is the path
forward really
lawsuits from victims or actual actions
against Saudi Arabia to dismantle what
would effectively be proven to be a
terrorist state if you believe that the
Saudis were responsible even in part
even indirectly for the 911 attack isn't
it an act of war against the United
States how are civil lawsuits the full
extent to which this should be pursued I
don't know Pat maybe I'm missing
something but to me if we can actually
demonstrate that Saudi Arabia was
providing material support to the
perpetrators of 911 all we're going to
do is let a widow sue them civilly it
seems like not enough to me yes not the
right way to go and if you remember last
summer there was a 28-page report yeah I
don't know which government n'avons
agency put it out but they concluded
that the Saudi government did not take
an active role in supporting al-qaeda
although they may have uh ignored
fundraising deliberately that's right
this was the the this infamous 28 pages
which over the summer were partially
unredacted and they were relatively
inconclusive I mean as Pat is saying
here they did not uh confirm definitive
support but at the same time they didn't
rule it out and so now we have via these
lawsuits the opportunity to actually
look at the evidence and maybe come up
with something more definitive and I I
know that there are some neo-cons who
have said I don't remember if it was
Michael Chertoff or who it was said hey
let lawsuits forget about lawsuits if
Saudi Arabia was demonstrably supporting
the eventual terrorists of the 911
attacks that's an act of war and just
mere civil lawsuits are not sufficient
send me your thoughts on that I wonder
how quickly i'll be called some kind of
war hawk uh which would be completely
nuts because you know that that's not at
all what I am discuss this on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
reddit that's re d di t we will take a
break next canada making some really
good decisions about the war on drugs
and heroin use